gives the prince two and a half minutes
in Hawks looking to score
Trey goes baseline Donovan's in attack
mode
give me that's too old one break the
bead rises up it throws it down he goes
in I know it's cold outside but there's
no soup for you he blocks it starts the
fast-break there give give me that and
they're off and running and Zachary come
fly with me
let's go he's pretty deadly 46% three
threes doesn't start booth the dragon
been pried loose
that's good anticipation on the
pick-and-roll Clarkson steps into the
bottom country who Bray over the screen
Knox throw to the left hand
what a great play for Mitchell Robertson
role knock 6:9 finding the seven-foot
Robinson watch how he funds the ball
into the slamming in a gym in the road
compared to 30% at home I wonder if it
stands still alienated inside to me they
would be able to gather and he's playing
the three ball misses and Kyle Alexander
for Judy but moments ago made Justin
Jackson checks in the former our North
Carolina Tar Heel and there's armin
Bagley the rookie first duped and he
spends an Ole Miss last couple of games
with backspin and in the Ana's 29 to 3
point defense Baba saves this possession
stuffs it in
ain't definite send clay away
transition able to finish
shot kids up and we stay at ray right at
the free-throw line
[Music]
[Applause]
do tiger
[Music]
[Applause]
hustle folks that's only if I want the
ball morning you proud hustling
appreciate insistent Thompson finished
it off what I like about the whole place
better diesel
before that this is the guy here he goes
to the UH Patrol which he loves strikes
layup jacks go from straight up
extension previously the good defense
versatility here wheeler the dealer off
the glass he's got an excellent handle
right they have to do that to be
successful they also have to take care
of the ball he really stressed that
here's the LOB up top to go good start
right there point defensively but and I
think it's a thing a part of that part
is that the opposing teams nice move in
a great deep Rizzo by James axe bridge
haven't been forcing but here gallon
Larry gets special with the behind the
back so again the game is basically
where it was yeah it's a big advantage
for Sacramento and that is a beautiful
physical break bogey comes into the game
and just it's like just clockwork about
five more in a row I make this
interesting
just get a few stops there's one great
flock by pombe to do what they've been
doing get the ball to the paint and Trey
goes right in there murder from the
corner it's a three you talk about
another guy in this league who has a
quick trigger Carter falling forward on
the block against turning marketing on
the inside the finish are good catch by
subsidy measuring John Wall Sencha high
rainbow three the Mavs have made the
court for this one
you wanna do good look up right here
[Applause]
finishing kick I mentioned getting to
the finish line is what Dallas needed to
do they are kicking like a sprinter
after a long run to the finish it's a
great dog excellent pass from Lucca
elevation Smith driving it on Lillard
then he's got 5,000 is slipped he found
Luca
[Applause]
great step back three spit lost his
footing and then here's Linda Harvey
this tremendous ability to stay on
balance after stepping back
to have the strip to get that shot up
that's not necessarily an easy shot it's
just a great offensive place
[Music]
Lucca averages seven of pull jump shots
per game and shoots 41% now that may not
sound like